lately we've heard a lot of talk about  global warming and the initiative by  greta thundberg what is she talking  about and how is the earth getting  warmer  this is due to the greenhouse effect  the greenhouse effect is a process that  occurs when the gases in earth's  atmosphere trap the sun's heat this  process makes earth much warmer than it  would be without an atmosphere the  greenhouse effect is one of the things  that makes earth a comfortable place to  live  so yes we do need the greenhouse gases  to trap the heat otherwise we would be  looking at an ice age  but  the emission of greenhouse gases has  increased and hence the earth is getting  warmer a greenhouse is a building with  glass walls and a glass roof  greenhouses are used to grow plants such  as tomatoes and tropical flowers  so how does it work  check the first comment  you